[Music]
come now mary magdalene
stand and be forgiven for your sins
but jesus how can i be forgiven
i'm a prostitute no child
you were a prostitute that life is
behind you now
where are you at [ __ ] oh no jesus i
think it's my pimp
i think he found me oh
there you are man it took me forever to
find your
ass i'm gonna be looking all over for
you you know how many [ __ ] named mary
they're up in here
now get your wheels in that caravan no
no i'm not going with you gala leroy
i'm gonna stay here with jesus what the
flip is this
you washing this maybe what i taught you
that
i wrestled you from the fishing village
i cleaned you up and got you out to work
and now that's how you repay me you go
get yourself another pimp hell no
brother she's mine
i don't think you understand she's not
going with you well i can't afford to
lose
i already lost three [ __ ] to leprosy
all right all i got left
is mary a [ __ ] and two blind chicks
who actually you know they get requested
a lot don't ask me
how that works get out of here i'm not
going with you galileo
i'm staying here with jesus and i'm
warning you jesus has like
12 followers tell them oh 12.
okay all right so this [ __ ] a
serious pimp no my friend you're
confused
it's 12 men uh are you a gay pimp i'm
not a pimp
i'm a carpenter carpenter
then why does your house look like i've
been busy with non-carpentry work
okay that's it [ __ ] packing get in the
caravan and make me some money
no and i don't have any stuff to pack
jesus says we don't need
things what the is this all about money
hell yeah it's all about money brother
i have a saying oh it goes like this
you're gonna love this
shut up it's easier for a camel to pass
through the eye of a needle
than for a rich man to enter the kingdom
of god
oh yeah well i got a saying too
it's easy you know why don't you pass
your own
pass your ass through the needle man
[ __ ] you man
come on girl stairs
i slapped you and you want me to hit you
on the other cheek
that ain't gangsta this is crazy you can
have them i'm done
wait friend so you know that there are
no hard feelings
would you care to join us for dinner
[Music]
what y'all have
you